what you're seeing here is a person
hiding for their life this terrorist
unfortunately he's not being called the
terrorist we have reports of a Texas man
gunman shooter this terrorist killed 20
human beings injured around 40 in his
manifesto he starts out by basically
praising the Christ Church shooter
another terrorists who massacred 51
innocent human beings women and children
included in a house of God and New
Zealand it's unfortunate and very sad
that this is becoming much more frequent
these types of terrorists and the media
unfortunately doesn't even call
terrorists but these terrorists keep
popping up their religion is not
mentioned affiliation with any religion
there doesn't seem to be any serious
attempt to try to connect it to a
religion like we see in many or majority
of the other cases when the person is
somehow connected to being a Muslim
we're not getting a reality show of his
home or their homes if there was any
imagine if there was any sniff of this
guy ever having anything to do with
Islam
maybe he checked out a book on
comparative religion and Islam happened
to be one of the religions ways of life
in that book or he imagined he sat next
to a Muslim on a bus or maybe he watched
the message with that the
Quinn how do you think that story would
have went what are you guys thoughts
leave in the comments Green's a peace
assalamu alaikum it is a statistical
fact that muslims do not commit most
acts of terrorism domestically or
globally it's statistical you can't
argue with it it's objective research
data that muslims do not kill more than
other faith groups and that muslims do
not commit most terrorist acts from our
shootings in the United States however
the way that a San Bernardino is treated
as opposed to a Las Vegas puts us in a
situation in which we feel like at times
we can't win because we have to defend
every lunatic that takes one life or 16
lives whereas other groups of people are
given a pass even when a person may be
claiming their faith or belong to their
their group and could murder 60 people
without anyone facing any repercussions
for that and our children have to bear
the burden of that if you think about
how unjust that is between the years
2000 and 2016 the white supremacist were
responsible for more homicides than any
other domestic extremism movement and I
will say that a majority of the domestic
terrorism cases that we've investigated
are motivated by some version of what
you might call white supremacist
violence but it includes other things as
well